esta torta que se hornea rápidamente y
pesa en torno a 90 gramos recibe el
nombre de Ice que en el dialecto local
significa pan pero también vida un
ejemplo de su importancia en la dieta de
los egipcios pero en el último año su
precio se ha duplicado hay bolsas de
cinco panes por 10 libras y de 7 por 15
ya sabes está todo caro
la dependencia de Egipto de las
importaciones le hacen muy vulnerable a
las fluctuaciones del mercado provocadas
por la invasión de Ucrania Egipto es el
mayor importador de trigo del mundo
compra el 60% de su grano en el
extranjero Y hasta febrero de 2022 El
80% de esas importaciones venían de
Rusia y Ucrania el saco de harina
costaba 200 libras Y ahora cuesta 700 u
800 que podemos hacer
en diciembre Egipto obtuvo un préstamo
del fondo monetario internacional que ha
hecho que su moneda pierda el 50% de su
valor frente al Dólar
cobro 200 libras al día Cómo puedo
alimentar con eso a mi familia
en enero la inflación alcanzó casi el
26% acumulado Aunque Alimentos como el
pan la leche o la carne han subido un
50%
algunos productos se han visto afectados
mucho más que otros por la inflación lo
que hará probablemente que en los
hogares se consuman menos
para paliar la recesión el gobierno
abierto decenas de puestos Donde se
vende comida con descuento también ha
incrementado los subsidios alimentarios
para decenas de millones de personas
registradas en el Sistema Nacional de
racionamiento un sistema del que se
benefician casi las tres cuartas partes
de la población
la gente no se puede permitir dejar el
pan con el incremento de la inflación
van a consumir más que otros tipos de
comida porque no se pueden permitir
comprar otro tipo de alimentos
al menos un tercio de su población vive
por debajo del umbral de la pobreza y
los expertos coinciden en que cada vez
más egipcios están en riesgo de tener
inseguridad alimentaria